the tri and start magic is
spreading he means to end the bloodline
it's been five long years since Aquaman
washed ashore for DC but now the
character has returned to help bring
closure to the DC euu as we know it
while trying to save a few kingdoms
along the way but can he save us all
from inflation no I'm just kidding
here's everything you need to know
before you go see Aquaman and the lost
kingdom We're The End Of The
Bloodline no we're not before we look
ahead here's a quick look back at
Aquaman released in 2018 and starring
mimoa as Arthur Curry AKA Aquaman his
second DCU appearance after Justice
League the year prior the fresh Aquaman
was directed by James Juan and it marked
the sixth installment in the DCU now in
it he's tasked with stopping his half
brother King orm from bringing together
the seven underwater kingdoms to
basically destroy the surface world it's
always another family member that causes
us the most drama now of course Aquaman
prevails and ascends to the throne as
king of Atlantis while sparing orm's
life in the process a key plot for the
sequel FYI we're going to put a pin in
that now the movie gross over $1.1
billion worldwide making it the highest
grossing DCU film and Warner Brothers is
now third highest grossing one ever
Barbie's number one and last Harry
Potter movie is number two a doll a
wizard and a merman all walk into a bar
no I'm just kidding I'll spare you now
of course back then a sequel was top of
mine but then a pandemic happened and
then Hollywood happened and yada yada
yada now we're here and by here I mean
the arrival of Aquaman and the lost
kingdom now from what we know so far
this 15th and final DCU installment
takes place several years after the
events of the first film this time
Aquaman has to protect his loved ones
and all of Atlantis for that matter from
an ancient power that was Unleashed by
Black Manta when he obtained the cursed
black Trident ironically Aqua is going
to need some help from his very enemy
from the first film his half brother orm
that is me taking the pin out I mean
Family Guys it is complicated now
bringing this story to life will be
plenty of familiar faces some of those
joining mimoa from the first Aquaman
movie include Yaya Abdul matine II as
Black Manta Patrick Wilson as orm and
Nicole Kidman as atlana along with Dolph
lungren tomor Morrison and our boy
Randall Park who plays Jimmy woo in the
MCU and marine biologist Dr Steven Shin
for this franchise Randall we love to
see it the legendary Julie Andrews Who
provided the voice of a mythical
Leviathan and Keeper of the Trident in
the first movie does not return nor does
Willam defo as Arthur Curry's men now we
also know that Ben Affleck's Cameo as
Batman has been cut for a few reasons
according to the Hollywood Reporter when
it comes to new faces we know that
Vincent Reagan will play atlan the first
king of Atlantis after the role was
played by various others in previous
films plus Jean Zhao is playing the
character Stingray indiia Moore is
playing Ken and Palo asbc who you might
recognize from Game of Thrones has an
undisclosed role along with James Juan
getting back in the director's chair
here's who else helped made this thing
happen so Juan who made his name in the
horror genres Conjuring Universe also
co-wrote the script once again with
David Leslie Johnson McGoldrick that is
a very long name who worked on this one
too now this time they got some help on
the writing side from Mamoa who's
credited for the story and has publicly
been more involved with the script since
the filming of the first movie in fact
it was actually his initial idea and
pitch that got the ball rolling for this
sequel I mean if you're going to be
Aquaman you might as well be Aquaman you
know the world of superhero franchise
acronyms is getting pretty confusing so
don't worry we're going to clear all
this up for you A lot has happened
between these Aquaman movies and the
biggest thing was a restructuring of DC
studios in 2022 from that James gun and
Peter saffron were put in charge and the
dceu As We Know It with people like
caval and Affleck is over and done after
this Aquaman film in fact Shazam Fury of
the Gods technically served as the start
of the new DC Universe back in March a
soft reboot of the old DC EU this new
franchise will eventually have United
continuity across TV movies and video
games and while Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom doesn't seem to fit in with
those plans mimoa could still return to
the franchise as a different character
and I got to say you never know if this
movie makes enough money I'm sure
they'll find a way to work it back in
you know what I mean okay friends that's
everything you need to know before you
go see Aquaman and the lost kingdom in
theaters December 22nd thank you so much
for watching and be sure to rate and
review this film at Rotten tomatoes.com
[Music]